now before we go any further one two
three
I'm going to do with you a classical
mathematical problem solving strategy
which will help you in any kind of topic
not just to do with vision or pinchable
and arrangements and all that kind of
thing which is part of why this problem
is too complicated to really wrap our
heads around is you're like I don't know
15 people I don't really know what's
going on there's too much happening
right so the classic problem solving
strategy that I suggest you use and
we're going to talk through this and you
stop me at the point or jump in when
you're like I think I I've got an idea
here even if it's not an answer is let's
just consider a much simpler version of
this problem and then just kind of play
out what's happening and see what's
going on okay so 15 people way too many
for us to actually put my own bag away
for us to really like draw and represent
what do you think is a reasonably like
small enough group of people that we
could try and
work out what happens in this situation
five
can I ask and you can say I just guessed
but I'm curious why did you say five
yeah can I can I suggest it's not a bad
number because you know there are some
numbers that are so small it's like well
there's kind of no point right for
example two people
tell me why that's not a good option
nothing interesting happens right the
two people come in they shake hands and
I should say by the way even though
that's like not useful for our problem
here it's too simplified it's still true
isn't it right the two people come in
uh A and B they shake hands that's it
there's no more shaking that can happen
because no pear shakes hands twice is
this true and the answer is yes the two
people are the only ones there let's
think about three for a second
think about it for a moment
so now I've got a B and C right
I'm going to get to a case of five in a
second but I want to build my way there
okay
what could happen
well for starters actually uh nothing
could happen right I mean I know they
said people start shaking hands but in
this situation right now is the the
statement that they've suggested to us
is it true
the answer is yes right because so far
all three people have never shaken hands
with anyone so they're all at zero as it
were okay but even as I start to think
about what happens right at each stage
because if I look back at the question
you look back at it with me as well
um many handshakes happen but we don't
know how many like it's kind of
open which is part of what makes this
problem a bit vague and confusing right
so what might happen lots of different
things could happen if those first two
original people they shook hands right
at this point right here
does the statement
I'm going to call this um statement s by
the way just so I can stop saying this
statement is as true at this point
it is right and maybe what you want to
do with me
um by the way I'm writing to think
it's gonna sound strange this writing is
a way of communicating thinking to you
but it's also actually my way of
constructing my own thinking so I highly
encourage you whatever it is you want to
drop down this is me trying to think
through the problem at the moment I'm
just keeping a tally of how many
handshakes have happened for each person
in the situation so far I've got one one
and then zero yeah so far so good s is
still true
pick another couple of people to shake
hands
who would you like to shake hands
ANC
okay so a second handshake has happened
this person's up to two handshakes now
now this person's up to one so it's all
still true right s is still true it's
just true with different people
yes following Divya yep
I already know it's true at this point
but why not why don't we just make them
all shake hands with each other so B and
C now shake hands and at this point well
what happens to my tallies
two and two it's at least two so the
fact that all three of them have done
the same number of handshakes is totally
fine okay
all right let me pause for a minute
you tell me what happens for four we're
gonna get to five in a minute but I
actually wonder if we need to go up to
five for you to sense what pattern is
forming here can I just pause for a
minute I'll actually there you go here's
a b c and d
you have a go you model what's happening
in this situation I don't know why I
drew a d so much lower than the rest of
them
and then you see if you can help me
reason through what this has to do
with the pigeonhole principle
maybe I should just ask before I let you
go what is the pigeonhole principle
again can you state it for me
I'll give you a clue it has to do with
pigeons and holes
do you remember
good so the whole idea is um and it's
it's so strange because none of us deal
with pigeons at all and we don't put
them in holes but you can picture it
right if you've got um say for example
uh four pigeon holes right and you've
got five pigeons
okay you know that there's gonna be at
least and assuming they all go into
their pictures okay there's going to be
at least one pigeonhole where there are
two pigeons they have to be right
because after you put in one here and
then one here and then one here and then
one here you're like uh oh I've got my
fifth pigeon to put in but he has to or
she has to be in the same pigeon holes
one's already taken
can I say that one more time and I
wonder if you're connecting it to this
yet right there are four available spots
even after they're all taken the fifth
one has to go somewhere and there's a
reason why there are only four pigeon
holes possible in this situation so let
me pause right there and just have a
think about the four people and what has
to happen just pause there and give you
some time to think
I see you guys are still thinking are
you guys at a brick wall at the moment
that's totally okay it just means I will
not make you keep on beating your head
against the brick wall yeah trying to
jump in yeah
okay here's where I'm hopefully because
what I want to try and do is like I
could just read out the answer to you
but that's not helpful right I need to
get you to that point so I want you to
return back to this idea of the
pigeonhole principle because at the
moment you've heard the pigeonhole
principle but you're like I don't know
what the pigeons are and I don't know
what the pigeon holes are and that's the
problem right once you know
sorry to keep on using the metaphor but
then they named it it's not me once you
know what the pigeons are and once you
know what the pigeon holes are that's
pretty much all there is to the problem
and then at the end you say by the
prison Hall principle and then you walk
away from the problem so let me give you
a suggestion about well I'll ask you the
question I think it might be not that
difficult in this situation what do you
think the pigeons are
they're people they're like the only
objects that there are right so I'm
going to suggest
these are our pigeons
now the whole idea of how many pigeon
holes are there is each of the pigeons
matches up to something now in this
question what is this something we're
trying to match them up to
it's the number of handshakes
the number of handshakes is the
Pinschers or you could do it vice versa
it's a symmetrical relationship right so
I'm going to call these the pigeon holes
so returning back to my illustration
here and um thank goodness I'm not
drawing any opinions for you because I
can't
if I can prove that there are fewer
pigeon holes than pigeons
like say for example four pigeon holes
five pigeons right that means that at
least two of them are in the same
pension hole which is the same do you
see that's that phrase there at least
two of them who are
in the same pigeonhole that's me
translating this language into this
question how are you with that so far is
that okay
all right now let's just have a look
back at our situation of four people
okay because I think this is
um now it's starting to get complicated
enough but manageable okay
hmm the pigeon holes are the number of
handshakes that are done right now given
some of the information in the question
you can already tell me
for example what's the maximum number of
handshakes that happens in this
situation of four people like for A or B
or C or D what's the most handshakes any
of them can do
three how did you get three
how do I think right like this is the
part that you guys need to do if I tell
you then it's me doing the work not you
right why is it three well at least two
reasons number one I mean you can have a
look at the two previous examples that
we just did right you can follow the
pattern I didn't mark it in but they
both did one handshake and then they're
done finished they both they all did two
handshakes and then like oh I'm finished
right why is it that it has to be I
guess if you call this n
the maximum number of handshakes has to
be n minus one
you can't shake hits it yourself so
there's four people here but I'm like I
can't I can't do that so the only
options are the other three people yes
so because it's the other people minus
you you're the one right so that's why
you end up with this um n minus one
okay does that make sense so far